ويرجعوا التحول النوعي في القدرات
الاوكرانيه لصد الهجمات الجويه الروسيه
الى منظومات الدفاع الجوي التي تسلمتها
كييف من دول غربيه خلال الاشهر الماضيه
والتي نستعرض ابرزها فيما يلي من منظومه
الدفاع الجوي الامريكيه
التي تسلمتها
ويمكنها ان تعترض الطائرات المروحيه
والمسيره وصواريخ كروس كما يمكنها ايضا
الاشتباك في ان معا مع 72 جسما جويا
معاديا في وقت واحد
من الولايات المتحده تسلمت اوكرانيا ايضا
منظومه الدفاع الجوي في ابريل لسان الماضي
ويمكن لصواريخها الاعتراضيه الوصول الى
ارتفاع اليزيدو على كيلو مترين ويمكنها ان
تضرب اهدافنا على بعد 160 كيلومترا اما
منظومه الدفاع الالمانيه من طراز ايروس تي
اس ال ام فتسلبتها
من برلين في اكتوبر تشرين الاول من العام
الماضي ويصل مدى صواريخها الى 40 كيلومترا
ويمكنها ضرب اهداف على ارتفاع 20 كم